ce qui nous entoure obéit à des lois
mathématiques bien précis se fait déjà
deux ans contre vu sur scène au québec
une longue absence que que s'est il
passé depuis
ben je me suis attaqué au marché
français donc sa nécessité et des
quelques allers-retours là bas
[Musique]
ça pas été facile en fait c'était
l'entrée à la télé leur est très
difficile une espèce d'inertie a brisé
qui est vraiment vraiment difficile
donc en fait on est on est passé par le
web c'est la technique on a utilisé au
début j'avais je pense 2500 abonnés sur
ma chaîne youtube cette chaîne qu'on
alimente est pour beaucoup
donc on a misé là dessus je fais les
tournées des capsules avec des artistes
français qu'on a mis sur la chaîne
youtube dans quelques mois le nombre
d'abonnés à passer de 2500 au dessus de
115000 dans 70% des français donc
souhaitais a connu un grand succès suite
à son a réussi à entrer à la télé
certaines certaines productions ont
acheté les capsules qu'on avait fait
pour le web pour les diffuser la télé
donc c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi notre
entraîneur si je fais ça y est tu m'as
vu lancer dabbagh dans ma main n'est ce
pas c'est parce que j'ai fait ce que
j'ai fait ces échanges et dabakh pour la
tomate qui était doyen nouristan
après la france tu veux aller aux états
unis en 2020 2021
pourquoi les studios basse et le marché
anglophone en fait ce serait le prochain
défi c'est l'espèce de marche qui reste
pour être vraiment être construit comme
un artiste international à partir du
moment où on performe en anglais de
performer à peu près n'importe où sur la
planète donc je dirais la prochaine
grande étape puis j'ai conçu le deuxième
spectacle aussi pour qu'ils se
traduisent relativement bien ce qui se
faisait moins bien avec le premier le
premier show donc
oui c'est un peu la raison pour vraiment
devenir un pour l'instant on en fait je
réussis bien en france et au québec donc
dans le milieu les francofolies je vais
te rend donc les états unis je pensais
vraiment la prochaine étape est beaucoup
plus de compétitions au niveau de la
magie là mais la signature que j'ai je
pense est assez différent de ce qui se
fait pour
pour quelle place pour qui un marché
pour ça que c'est ce que je vais
exploiter mais tu parles assez bien
l'anglais
il faut que le profil je le parle assez
bien pour pour interagir avec les gens
avec pour skill d'entraîner une foule
pendant une heure et demie pour avoir de
la répartie to forget le profil donc ça
me fait partie des défis non
ces voyants tu célèbres des dix ans de
carrière
alors la question qui se pose comment se
relever c'est une bonne question
ses dix ans de carrière à la télé
j'avais commencé très jeune à faire de
la magie
comment on se renouvelle mais en fait
moi le espèce de truc que j'ai pour pour
offrir des numéros qui ont jamais été vu
c'est d'être à l'affût de tout ce qui
est nouveau dans notre société que de
l'exploiter par exemple il y avait il ya
dix ans les téléphones portables
c'était presque que c'était aujourd'hui
donc maintenant avec un téléphone qui
peut jouer une vidéo qui peut être faire
différentes choses il ya des numéros de
magie quand vous qu'on peut imaginer
qu'on prépare ferrieu dix ans le rideau
va monter par deux ce matin mais ça ne
sera que pour quelques secondes
seulement
[Musique]
avant
je suis bien que l'angevin j'ai 13 ans
et je veux devenir un grand magicien je
pense comme être humain on évolue
n'importe quel artiste vit des choses
dans sa vie moi je viens d'être peuple
sas a bouleversé ma vie donc j'essaie de
m'inspirer de ce aussi deux heures le
spectacle maintenant demain porte le
titre maintenant dos mais parce que avec
l'arrivée de nos enfants je me rends
compte du temps qui passe beaucoup si
beaucoup ce qui est teinté la trame
narrative du spectacle est-ce que ça
t'arrive défaut de rater un taux c'est
très rare parce que j'ai un avantage
quand je commence un tour de magie les
ans les gens ne le savent pas où comment
ça va se terminer finalement donc quand
je vois que les choses fonctionnent pas
comme je le veux puis que je pouvais pas
terminée souvent j'avais plan b un plan
c puis je pense plus enveloppe je
termine le numéro autrement puis souvent
les gens m'aiment pas connaissance que
le numéro pas fonctionner si je prends
la pièce dans ma main et droite puis que
je donne quelques prunes marqueur dessus
soit qu'on a vraiment illusion quelques
semaines soit à tourner mais je
travaille également sur un projet de
livre
oui qu'est-ce que ça vous raconte je
peux pas vous en parler c'est sais mais
je sais ça garde ses secrets
non je peux pas vous en parler je
faisais ça sort pas de biographie ni au
niveau de recettes ni aux livres de
recettes n'en faut savoir miser sur ses
forces g non c'est évident ça vaut
porter sur son illusion même sur la
science je dirais
je mange relevé le voir un peu sur les
dessous de la magie 101 sans trop en
révéler mais je veux que les stations
lives en feu qui voilà qui va en dire
plus sur le milieu de lyon mais je peux
pas vous en dire plus en ce moment le
besoin du clan jri merci beaucoup c'est
un plaisir philippe